good day everyone and welcome i'm jack
van horn from the university of virginia
and i am proud to welcome you to this edition
of our 2021-2022 foundations of biomedical
data science seminar series the lecture series is
supported by uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia the uva brain institute
the college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from the
national institutes of general medical sciences
this year's theme is ethical challenges of
artificial intelligence and biomedicine where
we enjoy presentations on friday afternoons from
leading thinkers about the promise opportunities
and hurdles associated with ai applications in
the biomedical sciences selected participants
in our biomedical data science innovation lab
program have will leverage these presentations
as vital material for our culminating
in-person grant project development workshop
to be held here in historic charlottesville
virginia in june today i'm delighted to welcome
our speaker dr edward dove from the university
of edinburgh in scotland ted dove is a lecturer
in health law and regulation at the school of law
at the university of edinburgh and deputy director
of the j kenyon mason institute for medicine life
sciences and law he holds a bachelor's degree
in political science and civil law and common law
from mcgill university a masters of law degree
from columbia university and a phd in law from
the university of edinburgh his primary research
interests are in the areas of regulation of
biomedical research research ethics oversight
health-related data access and sharing health
data protection and governance of international
research collaborations his current research
focus lies in health data protection regulation
and research ethics committee for the national
health service in great britain he is an editorial
board member of the asian bioethics review and
formerly an editor-in-chief of scripted an online
peer-reviewed open access journal dedicated to law
medicine society and technology he is a co-chair
of the regulatory and ethics work stream of
the global alliance for genomic and health
and also a member of the scientific program
committee for the european society of health
genetics and a member of the edinboro law schools
research ethics and integrity committee he's
published works in such periodicals as science
the lancet the british medical journal european
journal of human genetics and several others in
ted's spare time he is also the author of the
open access monograph regulatory stewardship of
health research navigating participant protection
and research promotion and co-author of uh several
other uh legal uh treatises on on the use of
medical technologies uh and the legal implications
thereof in continuing our 2021 2022 biomedical
data science seminar series ted's lecture today is
entitled challenges for research ethics governance
in the era of ai and data science research in
ted's lecture he will explore contemporary issues
in research ethics governing looking in particular
at ethics committees within institutions such as
universities and the challenges these committees
face when assessing ethical issues associated
with ai and data science research he will argue
that while ethics committees are far from perfect
in terms of regulatory design and performance
they do perform at least in principle
a valuable role in helping steward research
projects towards an ethical endpoint and
while some modifications to their design and
performance might be warranted on the whole
they perform a very valuable service as always we
are streaming this lecture live and for recording
via youtube if you are watching on youtube
thank you so much for joining us once again
also our specially selected 2021 2022 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions they have for
ted via the chat feature in their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and ask them on
your behalf during the last 10 minutes or so of
the lecture and with that welcome ted we've
really been looking forward to your lecture
thank you very much jack and thank you gina and
thank you everyone at the university of virginia
for this wonderful invitation an opportunity
to speak with you all today thank you as well
for that and warm uh long biography that's um
overwhelming and it makes me think do i have any
free time in fact to do anything but i suppose i
do and the weekend is is nice so hopefully you all
have uh nice plans in store for this early early
spring time and hopefully the weather is very nice
wherever you are and indeed good morning good
afternoon and perhaps good evening to wherever
you are in the world and as jack said i want to
speak with you all for the next 45 minutes or so
um about ai and data science research which you
are all way more expert in than myself but i
want to situate that domain or those domains
within research ethics governance and with a
particular focus on the work of ethics committees
which are known of course in the us as irbs
research ethics boards are ebs in canada and
where i am in the uk research ethics committees
and in particular i want to make the case
that i think that data intensive science ai
type research is raising new and particularly
difficult challenges for research ethics
governance and in particular that
the work that ethics committees do
and i think it's worthwhile to spend some time
focusing on what those challenges are external
or internally imposed and whether it means that
we need to rethink the nature of research ethics
governance and in particular how these committees
are constituted and in other words is reform
needed and if so how radical must the reform be so
hopefully we can have a nice discussion about that
so in terms of what i want to do then over the
next a little while is go through four main areas
i think it's worthwhile to start looking
at the nature of ethics committees so both
are form and their function and i must say
that this presentation will try to have a
relatively high level view not necessarily
taking a specific jurisdictional focus
i am not situated in the us of course so my
knowledge of irbs and the common rule and hipaa
and related regulatory instruments is limited
i'm more knowledgeable of of uk frameworks and
so i will make more reference to the uk but i am
going to to endeavor to try to keep this as high
level as possible so that it will have resonance
with with wherever you are situated in the world
i'll then briefly talk about some some themes as i
see it from ai data science in big data and how in
particular those themes can throw up particular
challenges for research ethics governance and
the work that ethics committees do as part of
that we'll look at the changing role of ethics
committees and research ethics governance
and how there's been a confluence both of
long-standing criticisms and challenges that these
ethics committees face as well as novel ones as
they say that are raised by ai data science and
big data whether together that means are ethics
committees still fit for purpose can they do their
work well or are the criticisms and challenges so
valid that we need to actually think about reform
and as i say how radical reform is necessary
and so ultimately that that is where i hope
we can go and and we'll have as i say time
for plenty of discussion uh about this and whether
we think that research ethics governance and the
work work of ethics committee remain
fit for purpose in the 21st century
so let's start by looking at
the nature of ethics committees
i think it's worth first making an argument i
i won't have time to unpack this argument but i
think it's worth us starting with with a viewpoint
that the work of ethics committees is a form of
regulation and law and regulation are both very
uh notoriously tricky concepts to define not least
just because of cultural variation and ascribing
meaning to phenomena that we might say is legal
or regulatory so there isn't there's necessarily
going to be varying definitions depending on one's
viewpoints epistemology culture and so on we might
define law at least in its positivistic sense as a
system of rules codes pronouncements promulgated
by state or state like actors within a particular
community so it could be national sub-national
international with the aim of regulating the
actions of its members and which it may enforce
by the imposition of penalties so we can think
of judgments from a court of law we can think of
course of acts of a parliament or of congress uh
state like or state actors that write rules make
pronouncements judicial announcements or otherwise
and that have the backing of of the state in other
words imposition of law penalty sanction and so on
we can contrast that with regulation which i
think is a broader category and include can
include much more flexible and innovative forms
of social control so and this definition i i took
from from the book that jack reference regulatory
stewardship of health research i think regulation
to be more broadly defined as i say so we could
say it's perhaps a set of rules principles
mechanisms strategies or activities that can be
promulgated both by state actors but as well as
non-state actors that ultimately seek to affect
behavior either as an incidental effect of
probably more desirably to steer behavior in some
socially politically or economically desirable
way so in this definition the state is
not necessarily privileged it's simply
one node amongst many actors that
can share control of the sources
what that means then is that we might see that
various sorts of of actors or bodies including
irbs and ethics committees as regulators they
are seeking to steer researchers in a socially
and obviously ethically desirable manner so their
work is a form i would argue of social control of
science and indeed a form of regulation i think
it's really important to emphasize that point
why because when we turn to start to look at
how research and i define research very broadly
applying some sort of scientifically sound method
to derive generalizable knowledge not necessarily
just health research or other forms of research
we can think of research so in so many different
ways but generally research involving humans
of course directly or indirectly but brings us
into the realm of research ethics governance
as well as as we'll talk about shortly uh
data involving humans so again we can think
of human involvement in broad and broadening
sense but research itself is regulated through
a patchwork of instruments of regulatory control
we can think at the highest level of ethical
frameworks so thinking with our biomedical hats on
we might think about the declaration of helsinki
which of course has been in existence since the
1960s before that in the nuremberg code from
1948-49 the scions guidelines medical sciences
based in geneva they've come out with with new
guidance from 2016 but originally was from 1982.
we can think of public law so administrative laws
announcements from courts of law criminal law
domestic and international legislation so every
country will have clinical trials rate legislation
medical devices legislation and this is of
course just looking at the biomedical context
depending on where you are situated in the world
you might have human rights instruments that apply
to those of us who are member states of the
council of europe which is currently 47 member
states perhaps one less recently um abides by
the european convention on human rights and so we
have domesticated that in the uk through the human
rights act 1998 but many countries will have human
rights legislation that apply to it that might
have even been domesticated through through
domestic law so the highest level we could think
about the universal declaration of human rights
from 1948 at the united nations as well as the
international covenant on civil and political
rights from the 1960s and some countries have
adopted the economic and social uh rights
uh international declaration from the u.n as
well we can also think about common law and by
common law i mean law that has uh um promulgated
through judicial pronouncement not through acts
of congress or parliament so confidentiality law
is primarily a common law uh domain professional
secrecy and tort law contract law much more
driven by judicial pronouncement than a statute
professionals and governmental guidance is also
a key element of research and regulation thereof
so we can think about um certain professional
bodies researchers themselves of course are
not professionals but they might be um you
know ai is increasingly becoming a sort of
professional workforce or data scientist there
might be professional associations that put out
codes of conduct for how those that are seen
to be professionals ought to conduct themselves
ethically in going about their work there might
be a regulatory authority in place so in the uk
we have the health research authority in the
domain of health research but there are other
regulatory authorities that might be at play of
course if you're doing a clinical trial in the us
that the fta would be most at play but there might
also be funders who have their policies so quasi
quasi regulators so that's further down as you
see the nih of course will have its own policies
and what i'm trying to emphasize here is
ethics committees which i've highlighted are
but one node in this patchwork of instruments of
control but they played an incredibly important
role as i'll emphasize in a minute but i just
wanted to put this up here to really illustrate
the patchwork of instruments of
control that are at play here
ethics committees you know we often talk and
think about them as if they've been in existence
uh forever um but of course research itself
or the modern form of research and science
really only came about um in the 18 i don't
know 1870s and 1880s primarily in russia
when when when leading scientists there started
to to conduct um and apply scientifically sound
methods to develop generalizable knowledge not
through observation but through experimentation
and that's really been in existence in the 1880s
and from roughly 1880s 1870s through the 1950s
it really much was a case of um virtue virtue
ethics let's say being applied by the researcher
by the physician scientists by the um aristocrat
who had a hobby on the side of conducting research
and an expectation that they ought to
conduct themselves in a virtuous manner
but there wasn't necessarily a kind of committee
at play or a body or a group of individuals who
would assess prior to any research experimentation
observational taking place uh to give it some sort
of ethical green license ethical approbation so
what we see primarily through the great work of
laura stark and historian at vanderbilt university
uh through her her fantastic book on irbs in the
united states um the modern form of the ethics
committee the irb can be traced to the 1950s and
in particular the nih clinical center for the
for the this new type of research participant
who came into being namely the healthy human
volunteer the non-patient an individual who would
willingly knowingly give themselves to science
and say i'm happy to participate in this trial
this this experiment subject of course to
knowing the risks and expected benefits
and anything else that is material for me to make
a competent decision and so you had the sort of
genesis in 1950s 1960s that started in the us and
really was put on firm and firmer footing with a
a u.s surgeon general memo to all recipients
of grounds from the u.s public health service
that more or less said if you want to be recipient
of a public health service ground uh which
which includes the nih and there needs to be a
prior review of the judgments of the principal
investigator in terms of the right welfare of
the individual of the appropriateness of the
methods used to secure informed consent and of
the risks and potential medical benefits of the
investigation there's a few things to note here
one already informed consent plain essential role
risks and expected benefits but notice also
the biomedical focus here and so it's really
important to emphasize as as many of you
might know anyway the modern ethics committee
and the genesis of ethics review really
started from biomedicine but of course
we know that it's expanded over the decades
to go well beyond just the biomedical domain
so it's important to then ask knowing that the
irb the ethics committee the wreck has been
an existence wreck meaning research ethics
committee that's the term we use in the uk
um for 70 plus years or about 70 years now what do
they do well because there's different ways that
we can we can investigate that question we can
we can survey ethics committee and members we can
survey research applicants who submit their
applications and protocols to an ethics
committee um we can we can we can interview um
tinkerine coomer did a survey of uk university
ethics committees um uh back in the early 2000s
and i it's still the most comprehensive report
we have of university ethics communities in the uk
but i very much think this is generalizable across
other forms of ethics committees it
certainly accord with what i saw in my
empirical research of nhs for certain ethics in
these national health services ethics committees
which we'll speak about in a second and i would
venture to say very similar to what happens at
university and institutional and review boards
in the united states and in other jurisdictions
perhaps number three is the basic element that we
would associate most prominently ethical scrutiny
of research applications the primary uh objective
and object of an ethics committee is to receive
an application with all the relevant attended
documents the protocol perhaps the information
sheet and consent form other things nowadays
including potentially a data management plan
depending on we'll speak about that in a second to
assess the the ethical issues that are identified
either by the applicant uh and or also by the
efficiency members and to determine whether or
not it's ethically acceptable in other words can
it receive approval from that moment of assessment
or does it need to be further inquiry in
terms of questions put back to the applicant
or concern that means that it needs to be rejected
and then resubmitted but there's a role that goes
beyond ethical scrutiny of applications alone
ethics committees also have a responsibility for
for ethical issues in a broader sense including
maintaining standards and provision of advice
to researchers not something i'll touch on
in a minute very much i would i would suggest
and indeed argue ethics committee members
also are there to provide advice and not
simply to police or sit or or or gatekeep
research from taking place they are
ultimately many of many of them researchers
themselves pastor currently who are there to
support researchers and ultimately to guide
their research project through the life cycle not
just there as they say to police and gatekeep and
to say yes no so the provision of ice of advice
is a crucial role we ought to keep in mind too
reporting and monitoring is a more interesting one
there it depends on the jurisdiction some and and
and guidelines or standard operating procedures
and otherwise some ethics committees are required
to have an annual review that they that they want
researchers once the projects have been approved
to send to them how has your research gone over
the past 12 months have you come across any new
ethical issues how are you addressing any ethical
issues that were identified both in the original
application or new ones that have come come into
place once your project has gotten off the ground
but generally ethics committees are there in what
we might call the x anti stage before things begin
they receive the application before the project
is meant to begin and that's that's understandable
in the sense that the only way to protect
participants are arguably the only way or
the best way to protect participants against the
risk of harm from materializing physical harm or
as we'll talk about the second informational
harm it has to be done before the research
itself commences before personal data is processed
before things actually start to come into being
but that doesn't mean that don't they don't have
or shouldn't have a role to play once the project
has gotten off the ground but it is to say that
reporting and monitoring i think it's fair to say
is limited limited because of resources and not in
other reasons and then lastly the responsibility
for ensuring production and maintenance of cohen's
practice and guidance is very much dependent
on the terms of reference of any given ethics
committee and where they sit in an institution
or or other body so if they are for example
and in the uk context universities often have
uh research ethics committees within a college
or at the highest level across the university
and then there's those that are situated
within departments or faculties or schools
generally the school and departmental ethics
committees do not uh write codes or practice
guidance but the higher level ones do and
very much will depend on the particular ethics
committee but some will have a responsibility
for producing codes of practice and guidance
when it comes to the role of an ethics committee
given that that's what they are seeing to do we
might ask so what's their what's their primary
objective beyond sort of assessing the ethical
acceptability of an ethics application well this
is taken from the health research authority's
governance framework for research ethics
committees gaffer as as it's known a tongue
twister vernacular and i should say that the
health research authority as the name implies
regulates health research in the uk albeit
very much big data driven machine machine
learning driven health research
but still in the context of health
and they have a responsibility for ethics
committees that are within the nhs the national
health service the health the health service
that exists in the uk remember in the uk health
health care is free or taxpayer funded i should
say and but it's free at the point of use and
and that means that there's a treasure trove of
data because everyone in the uk is an nhs patient
and across the four nations of the uk so
you're talking about 65 to 70 million at
individual data subjects so a tremendous troll
of data so a lot of researchers um often make
applications to these ethics committees to use
the patient's data that might be identifiable data
or or partially anonymized or fully anonymized
and so these efficiencies play a valuable role
it's worth noting that there are two roles that
and the governance framework for research ethics
committees identifies and the question is are they
are they situated on the same plane or is there a
primary role in the secondary role well it seems
that there is indeed a sort of primary role but
a really important secondary role the primary
role perhaps not surprisingly is the protection
of the interest of research participants
so this document speaks to their dignities
rights safety and well-being and that has to
be the primary consideration in any proposal
as well as in the ethics committee reviewed by
that research identity the wreck and of course
they talk about proportion of safeguards which
is important and something we'll speak about in
a minute but there's also the secondary role which
is acting primarily in the interests of research
participants and and that has to be secondary to
the dignity uh rights is the safety and well-being
of people taking part in research so that's
that's the primary that's primary the interests
of researchers in research must be secondary
to the protection of the rights and welfare
of participants themselves so what you see here
is there is an interest in value and a role for
ethics committees to be mindful of science and
society but it must necessarily be secondary to
the protection of research participants so that's
a really important point that we'll come back to
so we can think then there
might be this principle aim
in the second area and the principal name being
protection the welfare of perspective and current
participants as well as this secondary promotion
of ethical and socially valuable research
and think about that comment earlier about ethics
committees are also there to provide advice
and and perhaps to go beyond just that x anti
stage of policing and approving yes no an ethics
application but working with researchers to
provide support and guidance throughout the
life cycle of research and therefore that
secondary aim becomes really important
so this this notion of the evaluation of ethics
issues of a proposed project by committee of
people and ethics committee and irb qualified
in some way so it will depend on the particular
committee in terms of reference are there certain
experts that need to sit on the committee how many
must be experts in the field are there any lay
participants and so on and so forth but there's a
body of people committed people 12 to 18 somewhere
between the numbers to assess a project's ethics
issues we might say arguably that's that's
necessary but not necessarily sufficient
for the successful functioning of
the securing public trust in research
if it's not enough i would argue that if we
want to sustain public trust in any research
whether it's ai and big data juveniles we'll
get to in a second or otherwise that we say
oh it's been ethically approved and irb has
approved it it's we have to go beyond that
it's it's necessary but perhaps not sufficient so
it is simply a pragmatic system of social control
by by researchers academic and community peers
that's what irbs and ethics committees do they
it's a social control of science and that and
that's a recognition it's a pragmatic system
very much an american philosophy that's why they
started i would argue the nih clinical center is a
an ingenious proposal but it's very
pragmatic proposal too to have a committee of
of reviewers so we say but given where we're going
in science given where we're going to research
it can be queried whether this pragmatic
system of social control remains fit for
purpose in the 21st century particularly
in light of internationally collaborative
data intensive science and emerging technology
practices and so let's now focus then on the area
of ai data science and big data and think about
some of these themes that throw up challenges
or research ethics governance in
particular the work of ethics communities
so i don't need to tell you that all of the
advances in computational analytical techniques
analytic techniques and digital technologies have
led to a tremendous increase amount of digital
data produced and available to be processed that's
what we talked about with state big data you know
it's all obviously the three v's potentially five
e's potentially seven days there's a variety of
these to talk about volume variety velocity et
cetera et cetera but that's what we're talking
about tremendous advances in computational
analytic techniques and digital technologies
massive increase in data and that means then that
research projects increasingly are processing
a variety of data through a variety of means
this really is data hoovering on a large scale
and the ethos of course big data is
generally speaking the more the better
the more data we can collect the better
maybe we can find the signal in this
tremendous amount of noise that we're generating
but there's several themes then that emerge here
one we can talk about a shift from human subjects
the lingo the parlance that we talked about from
the 20th century tumor 21st century and this
obviously comes from data protection along europe
the notion of a data subject and that's the legal
term of course in data protection law but i think
that's perhaps what we're going to this is less
about the human per se it in a sort of corporeal
sense and much more about who they are in terms of
their data points so we are i think shifting from
a human subject to a data subject but also that
means when we think about research involving human
participants or research involving human subjects
of research and relating to human subjects
we shift from direct involvement more towards
indirect involvement and what does that mean
well partly when we think about the notion of risk
given that that's a primary form of assessment in
in the governance model that expedia is a sort
of risk assessment and calibration of standards
proportional to the level of risk of project rates
the risk also just from physical or psychological
harm towards risk of informational harm and
that's what we mean we move the data subjects
and indirect involvement of research participants
involving various data points dignitarian harms as
well as informational harms and so i don't need
to go into detail about the various methods that
apply in in ai and in data intensive research
all of those i assume you're well familiar with
as well as the various categories of data and the
sources of data from which these various data can
be collected the network can be open and closed
crowdsource can come from a variety of public and
semi-public or private databases as well so what
does that mean then well let's let's apply that
those sort of themes back to ethics committees and
we'll start with some of the classic criticisms
that have arisen with ethics committees and
think about how some of the new ones are also
being raised and what this means then for the
fitness for purpose tests that we'll talk about
well one we can't avoid the fact that ethic
communities have grown just as we're talking
about growth in data there is a growth of the
ethics committee as well so research itself has
grown the amount of research being conducted the
the international collaborative nature of research
the duration of research the
funding involved in research
and necessarily then we have to talk about a
growth of the regulation of research and of course
very few would argue that we should operate in a
world of zero regulation just as we should operate
in a world of economic trade and various sorts of
human activities in a form of regulation thinking
about again the definition of regulation steering
of human behavior in a socially or economically
and politically desirable manner how totally
what regulation is and so just with research and
its growth there has been a concavity rise of its
regulation and i've already made the argument that
regulation i think includes assessment of ethical
acceptability and we might indeed call irbs and
institutional review boards or research
activities research ethics regulatory
communities or institutional regulatory committees
but i don't think we'll shift in that parlance
at any time soon and but i think that's an
accurate reflection of what in fact they do do
it's also important in speaking about the
growth of the ethics committee the hybridity
of ethics committee systems in many countries
so the u.s is in to my knowledge an entirely
um institutional based system but that's actually
not the norm many countries operate a sort of
hybrid system like in the uk for example where we
have institution based ethics committees primarily
at higher education institutions so colleges and
universities as well as our region-based ethics
committee so the nhs research ethics committees
that are situated in the four nations of the uk
but still technically representing a region
of scotland england wales or northern ireland
ethics committees do retain a gatekeeping function
i think that is fair to say they do ultimately
play a role and they might arguably have to play
a role under a law depending on the jurisdiction
depending on the type of research if it's a
clinical trial that is a law that they have
uh to to review and assess and approve a clinical
trial before it can take place but there's all
sorts of research projects including your um you
know your master's level or phd level project that
involves perhaps uh personal data uh um or some
sort of involvement of human participants that
through policy or some form of regulation
also will require accuracy and therefore
they do keep they determine whether or not your
research as presented to them can go forward
but there has been a shift from this 1950s nih
clinical center ad hoc physician peer reviewer
to a quasi-professionalized institutionalized
diverse body of experts and what i mean by
that there's not a professional body
of irb members of rec members per se
but there are organizations like primr and the
us and other organizations and other countries
that seek to professionalize which is
not a bad thing the work of irb members
and administrators but that has created its
own sort of um various questions and ways of
working rituals and otherwise and that means that
there has been a growth of rules of standards
um and in turn reflections on on how
researchers go about doing their work including
the preparation of an application for ethics
review and so what we have then is a much more
institutionalized and embedded regulatory event
licensing system through ethics committees they
provide the event license to the applicant you can
you can proceed to conduct your research or not
so this of course this growth of ethics committee
in the work that they do has led to long-standing
criticisms not necessarily tied to ai and data
intensive science so the the primary criticism
is very much one of bureaucracy mission
creep red tape and a concern that we are now
living in a tick box tick box form of ethics
not one of the classic you know pre-pre-world of
pre-irb world of a virtue ethicist driven type
of research where the individual researcher
was expected through various sorts of social
norms and otherwise to conduct themselves in
a virtuous manner without the need for this
regulatory approval by an ethics committee
so in the uk in european context i can tell you
when the eu clinical trials directed 2001 came
into effect and that was 2003 it was domesticated
in the member states laws many countries thought
this was the end of self-regulation of research
ethics and there's now these these legal standards
that we need to abide by when it comes to ethics
committee review not just the clinical trials but
ultimately it came out to be all form of research
in this case involving nhs patients which as i say
and is a lot of health research in the uk given
the nature of our health care system and there
was a real lament of the 21st century leading to
an increasing amount of bureaucracy in terms of
the ethics application form increasing in length
he attended documents that needed to be drafted
to ultimately secure these approvals not just
ethics approvals of course but clinical trial
approvals from the drugs regulator and otherwise
so this this lament is really being sustained
by the research community and an article i think
this is from the british medical journal in 2008
and a biomedical researcher made the case that
in a risk benefit arena that is now heavily
stacked towards perceived risk the instigators
of over-regulation must bear responsibility
for the real and emerging risks but failure to
deliver the potential life-saving benefits of
clinical research properly in other words the
risk-benefit ratio is no longer uh calibrated
appropriately and risk is now heavily stocked
towards an over-assessment of all forms of risk
and and and those who are responsible they need
to think about what research is being thwarted
what research is being prevented from taking place
including life-saving research because of this
over-regulation bureaucracy and that tape now some
of these criticisms as they stress are hardly new
so you know i i remember reading an article from
dale cowan who was in the u.s irb chair wrote 1974
already in 1974 so this is only only you know less
than a decade after the u.s surgeon general's memo
of his concern about the sheer weight of the
bureaucracy which has been proposed to regulate
human experimentation many investigators in
review committees are already of the opinion
that the paperwork involved preparing approving
acceptance protocols as extensive and taxing and
in the textbook that i had at mason mccall smith's
law medical ethics we have a quote in our previous
edition that said one of the ironies in this
area is that there may now be so many instruments
regulations and guides that the system itself is
standing in the way of good ethical research so
that's been the sustained criticism over decades
this concern of bureaucracy and paperwork and
increasing amounts of paperwork that's extensive
and taxing both for ethics committee members
but certainly also for research applicants and
yet more recent criticisms particularly in light
of ai and science have come from the opposite
direction namely that it's too much bureaucracy
or sorry rather than it being too much bureaucracy
it's about under coverage in particular ai and
data intensive research so it's it's about gaps
and loopholes in research ethics governance
rather than mission-free bureaucracy and red
tape which is quite interesting to think about
how they come from very opposite ends so let's
look in particular at some of these challenges
one arguably is a scope challenge
thinking about these gaps and loopholes
in other words is ai and data science
research within the purview of ethics review
well i mentioned already how the paradigm of
ethics uh committee work and research ethic
government very much has come from biomedicine
and we see that from the declaration of helsinki
we see it from the nuremberg code and we see
it from from really from the common rule as
well n d for much of the bell monitoring for it
quite famous in the u.s which did give credence
to social science research but very much on past
songs shall we say so there really has been a bio
medical ethics framework application potentially
to ai and data science as well what that means
is it appropriate to take those concepts
and principles from biomedicine individual
autonomy and individual participant risks and
expected benefits as distinct from something
that might be more appropriate in ai and data
science research and i'm speaking about societal
risks and expected benefits group harms including
group privacy harms and informational dimensions
another question about scope is many countries
permit research projects to forego ethics review
or have it subject to a proportion of you if
anonymized data are used i believe that's the
case in the us i i will stand corrected if i'm
wrong that's also the case for example in the
uk and switzerland and but i think it's fair to
say also that it is increasingly difficult to
ensure that data actually fill whatever criteria
is necessary in in the uk and european products
as a legal criteria under general data protection
regulation and domesticated data protection acts
to establish that data are indeed anonymized in
other words fully and irreversibly de-identified
rather than personal or pseudonymized or let's
use the term key coded in other words can they
adequately and legally forego ethics review
because they in fact do not uh constitute personal
data i think that's an increasingly difficult uh
dimension and and difficult criterion to fulfill
and of course the risk of identifying individuals
from the data is often very difficult
to determine quantifiably or otherwise
and then there's another question is ethics
committee review required for research on
pre-existing data sets that's of course a
tremendous aspect of data science research it's
not about the generation of new data sets it's
research performed i've already collected data
and of course the question is can one or should
one rely on the underlying consent or permission
from those data subjects if there even is
a contest and and that's often not the case
and then there's another dimension about scope
which is privately funded studies may not be
subject to the same research protections and
ethical regulations as publicly funded research
you think about public-private partnerships
liaisons between universities and industry and
otherwise and what does that mean for obligations
to undergo ethics review or not and if so who
takes responsibility or is it the case that you
have duplicative multiple ethics reviews which of
course raises a number of challenges and issues in
its own right i think there's a second challenge
which is about assessing and operationalizing
these research participant consents in other words
thinking about this principle of no surprises
for data subjects is the research activity or
data posting activity you're going to be doing
would that would that come as a surprise to them
and would it be in accordance with their
reasonable expectations of data use and if the
answer to either question is that no i'm not sure
i think that that requires deep ethical reflection
but this is particularly because as i say when
it comes to secondary use quite often consent
might not be at play in that given data set
and we know in particular from social media
which are very often used for research purposes
without participants explicit consent or awareness
and that's just that just goes without saying
use of data collected from tick tock twitter uh
facebook and otherwise is not done with the
explicit consent awareness of any given user
about that social media platform and i think we
ought to very clearly distinguish more than we do
consent provided from a research ethic standpoint
versus what we call talk about in european
data protection law consent as a legal basis to
process personal data and we need to not conflate
those two concepts lest we confuse everyone
including participants ethics and new members
and researchers and how both of those concepts
fit in within reasonable expectations of privacy
so consent remains a very open question and
of course we also must not treat consent as
a panacea for all ethical concerns it shouldn't
be the case that we can say well we need a new
consent or let's rely on this old consent and
because there is a consent we can squeeze in
all the information we need to in other words
this kind of um can i say it almost a sort of um
liberal approach liberal in the sense of assuming
there's a rational individual and if we provide
all material information consent form they've
read it they've signed it they know what they're
signing up to buy or beware i think we have to
be careful about treating consent as a panacea
for all ethical concerns and not thinking about
larger sort of governance frameworks and and
and social norms and ethical norms we ought
to still abide by even if consent is there
and then finally there's this challenge of
disharmonization and inadequate expertise in
data science methods and data ethics so there's
two elements here of course we know there's
inconsistency across and within ethics committees
including within the same university or our region
and so the uk for example has not
resolved the issue of multi-site
multi-university research much less as they
say when there's collaboration with commercial
um in industry when it comes to data-driven
research so this lack of standardization and
consistency is a tremendous challenge from so many
countries this harmonization is a real concern
particularly when we speak about
internationally collaborative research
and another concern of course is the challenge of
an expertise a number of irb members and research
facility members i would venture to say are
not experts in data ethics data protection
law or i.t security and therefore they may well
feel outside their comfort zone when it comes to
reviewing an ai or data science project and
what what are what what rules or principles
or guidances in place for any given editing to
deal with that what happens i suspect many are
silent and it's just just to rely on the expertise
of any given irb or rec and you say well you know
you can apply the general principles and knowledge
you gained from your years as a member but
we i think can query whether that's appropriate
in this world of of data intensive science
so these i think are also two really
important challenges are two sub challenges
in this challenge three of disharmonization and
inadequate expertise so the question then becomes
you know these are serious challenges ethics media
is actually purpose still in the 21st century
well i want to make the case that yes i
think broadly speaking and to make it a
short answer also keeping keeping mindful of
time i think ethics committees do remain fit
for purpose broadly speaking their regulatory
design is not perfect nor is implementation
but much like we speak about
democracy being the least bad
of all other possible forms of government
we might say that ethics committees are the
least bad of all other possible structures
to serve as a social control of science
and to facilitate and promote those two names
of participant protection and ethical promotion
thinking again about the advice giving nature that
efforts means can or should instill and inculcate
but that doesn't mean that in light of these these
developing areas of science in particular ai and
machine human interactions and democratization
of science i think about citizen science
some modifications to research ethics design
or scientific governance design and performance
and is not warranted it is i think so i'll speak
very briefly about some of the themes that emerged
in the book that jack mentioned already
regulatory stewardship of health research
this was an empirical project that brought me
to england in scotland over more than a year
sitting in in various nhs research ethics meetings
and speaking with members and regulators and
conducting interviews a documentary analysis
and and of course field notes with my with
my sort of ethnographic type research and
ultimately um you know what i observed was
a lot of ethics companies don't don't
know what other ethics days are doing
you know there are these sort of networking
events that happen once or twice a year but
generally they operate in a black box in the
case of an nhs research efficiency there was
surprising and tremendous group homogeneity
in approach and rituals so one could be in
various ethics meetings in different parts
of the country but they would still operate
surprisingly similarly in terms of how they
conduct themselves the issues they discussed
but i can tell you now having in the midst of
conducting research that's still ongoing with
the university ethics committees in the uk very
different much more buried in approach and venture
to say institutional review boards institutional
committees generally operate very differently
but there is a strong emphasis to preserve
the sanctity of their black box and their
ethics of space even if they don't know what
others are doing they don't want to change
regulatory connectivity was another major
theme so law and science occupy these
uncertain relationships with epics means they know
they're not supposed to review the methodology the
scientific methods that should already be done
by the funder or someone else but they often do
review science and the methods and everything
that's necessarily a bad thing we know there's
an intertwining of science and ethics and indeed
law i think increasingly plays an important role
and we know it will through information governance
and data protection and privacy given the nature
of research in the 21st century i think ethics
committees can operate as stewards helping
researchers navigate these various spaces of
science and law more than they're given credit for
and so that third theme regulators of stewards
did really come through uh in my research that
they really can encourage researchers and support
them not simply be seen as police police persons
and watchdogs gatekeeping and saying yes no
only at the initial stage but really trying
to work with researchers throughout the life
cycle of their project to help them make their
research as successful and ethically valid and
as as possible and socially valuable as possible
so there is there are opportunities for
development and i'll just end i think um
not so much on these notions that came through uh
in in my work and if you're interested in reading
about and learning about regulatory
flexibility and conversations and stewardship
by all means you can have a look it is open
access so it's available on everyone at no
cost through through edward elgar so if you just
pull the book it should be available to you but
let me focus more about sort of the this domain
i'm thinking about ai and data intensive science
obviously resources for sources resources
are crucial here there needs to be systemic
support within institutions within
government and to provide greater
funding and yes professionalization possibly
paid training guidance and we'll talk about
sort of ad-hoc committees and pools of experts
and citizens in a moment but there has to be
much greater emphasis given to a system of
accreditation qualifications certification of
ethics committees standard operating procedures to
ensure procedural consistency i think there's real
value in templates often and templates are there
of course for inspiration they're not meant to be
carbon copied onto any given application but
they are tremendously invaluable particularly
when we're thinking about ai and data intensive
science and we need to think about how we draw
forms for these forms of research different
from the biomedical domain and the questions
and things that need to be thought about are
very different so i think template review forms
and information sheets and consent forms would be
tremendously valuable for the research community
and i'll also very brief that just the interest of
time give credence to a a project that i worked on
with agatha ferretti and effie bienna and their
team at uh zurich in switzerland and we had a
nice discussion um in the midst of the pandemic
about a year and a half ago thinking about ethics
review big data what should stay and what should
be reformed and we came up with sort of three sort
of categories of reforms so again not throwing
the baby out with the bath water we still think
ethics communities have a role to play but they
ought to indeed have reform some more radical
than others but generally not radically informed
but but important reform guidance would be really
valuable for research and research committees
and certificates as well as researchers on the
ethics issues within ai and data science research
and in turn help think about that scope question
is my research should should or must my research
be submitted to an ethics committee at all and
if so what do i need in this in the in
the course of submitting that protocol
that application for review you can think about
procedural reforms so new ethical assessment
tools that would be valuable to fxpds external
consultation those who are skilled in data science
and data ethics and data protection and i.t
security ethics committee members ultimately i
think should have training in ai and data science
research so they don't feel uncomfortable when
they receive an application from this domain
and and so that might that might lead to tweaks
to terms of reference as well as governance
frameworks for ethics committees themselves
and ultimately i think there's always scope for
more engagement with researchers and data subjects
more stakeholder engagement is absolutely valuable
here there might be a role for a new specialized
committee that sits alongside an ethics committee
namely a kind of data ethics committee or data
ethics review board but of course that will lead
to concerns about duplication and confusion and
so i'm not sure a specialized committee is
the answer or where we need to go just yet
so i think ultimately then uh it's not about
sort of a no more wreck i think we ought to think
about it though um going beyond as i say this ex
anti-regulatory licensing to um you know a more
embedding of ethics across a life cycle it's not
about going to expose review and audit so let all
research projects start without any ethics
review and we'll just sort of audit one out
of every 10 that have taken place and see if
anything went wrong i don't think that's the
right answer i think either committee should play
a role at the ex-ante stage to say think about how
it's embedded across the life cycle and i think
that's ultimately what this idea and concept of
regulatory stewardship is all about that's really
what i sort of emphasized in my book so i i leave
it for about five minutes for questions i very
very much thank you for your time and i'm happy to
to answer any questions so that's a a picture
of old college the law school the university of
edinburgh uh on a typical scottish weather day not
police guys and but not too bad never really much
snow and and i want to thank my current funder the
carnegie trust for the universities of scotland
who's uh funding me for my my ongoing research on
university ethics committees in scotland across
the scottish universities so thank you very much
thank you ted that was fantastic such a great
overview of things i think it you know transcends
as we sort of discussed a little bit earlier
transcends kind of international boundaries with
a lot of these uh irb and and regulatory aspects
to how we do science especially now that as you
kind of pointed out things are so data rich now
and one of the things i wanted to ask you is do
you feel that um institutional review boards and
those regulatory agencies uh you know you sort of
touched on this do you feel that they are getting
adequate training and they understand what kind
of the data sets are how big they are what kind of
there's always information about you know say
uh personal identific personal identifiers but
do you think they get a sense of like what the
goals of large-scale data science are are about
it's a great question jack i mean yeah the the
the short answer is no i don't think they are
um and it depends of course on the jurisdiction
so i can speak first of my my research involving
nhs for search ethics committees there
because those ethics committees are um
funded if you will by by the nhs in each of
the four nations and so in other words they're
sort of state-run ethics communities generally
there's a a much more consistent and standard
approach for induction of members both when they
join as well as ongoing sort of annual training
and there they often run workshops on sort of new
and emerging areas of research in of course the
context of of of health research and in particular
clinical research and biomedical research
um but i know that ethics means within those 86
i think committees there are nhs rex there are
across the uk i would venture to say there they
are relatively well trained and kept up to speed
on new and emerging methodologies including data
terms for science and big data type research
including for example all of the tremendous
cobia 19 research that the uk has led on genomic
sequencing and otherwise in these huge data sets
of of nhs patients which have led to already
tremendous breakthroughs in terms of of treatments
that that work for coca-19 patients patients
um from institutional ethics committees your irbs
or you know as what i'm discovering universities
in scotland it's much more of a grab bag some
universities provide training only when new
members join some provide not at all and very few
if any provide ongoing training including sort of
workshops for members on various sorts of things
and if they do it's sort of a voluntary thing
if if you're able to join when it works for your
schedule but i fear that that means that many
ethics committee members um are fumbling in the
dark with these with these sorts of of of data
intensive methods and the various ethics issues
that are are particularly related to ai um and
and related forms of research and and technologies
and therefore i think that it doesn't really help
participants it doesn't help researchers and
it doesn't help the ethics committee or the
institution so i think a lot more can be done but
as they say that's really a question of resource
and the question is is there the will to invest
more in the resources to provide that training for
our expertise so that ultimately are protected
data subjects are protected the institution is
protected and you're ultimately creating better
science as a result there's another organization
i think the acronym is cioms i'm not really
familiar with it but apparently they have
uh some ethical principles for epidemiological
research and it seems that these may be maybe
a little more informed about big data science
than say the original declaration of helsinki or
available acronym stands for but they
um or something i can't remember exactly
0:59:17.040,1193:02:47.295
the not
they they put out uh they put out since 1982 sort
of the international uh guidelines for research
involving participants originally the arena was
much more for research conducted in developing
countries the concern was the declaration
of helsinki and others was for researchers
conducting research in their own jurisdictions and
there was a concern that researchers were going to
other parts of the world that were that were had
less regulations and laws in place to protect
participants and there was concern of unethical
research being conducted primarily clinical trials
and and so that was original sort
of genesis of the 1982 guidelines
the more recent ones 2016 are seen as
sort of the gold standard for all forms
of of research involved between participants not
even within the biomedical context so including
epidemiological type research generally scions
is a is a fantastic organization that puts out
frameworks guidelines codes for researchers and
all different domains not only medical science
but that's still the primary one that they focus
on including for emerging technologies and and and
methods and techniques in data intensive science
so an organization like science would be great
in the sense that it's guidance that in principle
should be available to all committees and all
all participants all researchers internationally
the question is you know how much is it actually
focused on the particular type of research that
that researcher is conducting and how relevant
is it to that particular jurisdiction in terms of
their laws and frameworks otherwise but science is
a great example of organization that is trying to
make headway in this area are there any other um
resources or organizations or any scholars
that are also writing about this shift from
kind of human subject focused data to kind of like
big data as the research subject itself is there
there's some folks who want to read more about it
ah that's a great question jack um so i mean um
i'm trying i don't mean to
put you on the spot ted if you
if you were to though to maybe send us a list
of those we could make it available to our
participants i think that would be wonderful
i would be happy to understand i'd be happy to
provide a sort of uh reading list and viewing this
for those that might be interested in sort of um
data ethics research ethics issues related to ai
type research and you know thinking in particular
about um you know because i just read the second
edition of his book rob kitchen he's based at
manute university in ireland uh those who are
focused on critical data studies so thinking
critically about big data including implications
for society promoting big data research
but doing so in a way that is thought through the
societal implications and ethical implications
not to mention of course equal implications so
i think rob kitchen's second edition of his book
um came with the title top my head but that
it's really a magnum opus in the field so
um but i'd be happy to put together a little
short reading and viewing this for for everyone
that'd be wonderful well ted thank you so
much for sharing this uh great discussion
with us and and your work in this area this is
so important to the future of big data science to
you know how we're doing things with new ai
developments and and their applications in
understanding health and disease uh worldwide
so thank you so much for sharing the perspective
from edinburgh we really appreciate it um thank
you everybody who joined us and uh everyone have
a wonderful weekend and uh we'll see you
next week thanks again ted thank you thank